Nhi Anh, Đâm Mê Mòn Đỏ Đàn, thích nghiên cạnh phá hay kê ấy tiền.
Chắc không ăn nghề Anh, khoảng tâm dự, nghe mong hay tạng mề vụ, công an tị sát thái hoa,
nhìn được tin bảo từ nghen hàng xác công bán vận nhanh Việt công bán,
thuộc chi nghen thái hoa, có đẹp chỉ tại phụng hoa hiểu, tị sát thái hoa,
tìm viết hay kê ấy tiền của hàng nghen hàng bị kể sát kẹ phá, tích nhận tin báo,
công an tị sát nhân trong bỏ cuộc kế này cảm hiền gị trường.
Đông thời, thích lập các tổ công tắt sát mình chỉ xác khá mề ra anh đình, sất đình,
phó khoảng 1 xe bám vút, nghe mong hay tháng mề vụ, nè bài ngàn công trong hai mề tự,
có một lửa tượng nằm dưới mất áo chung đau,
bị kính nạn, đều khiển xem một tổ nhận hiệu hôm đà fiu chờ,
đi tế kế ấy em cũng hình hảnh xác công bán, dùm một tựa nhận xác bị kể phá,
sau đo lửa tựa tựa dị tiền và tiếp tục thực hiện hàng viên như trên
tại kế ấy em cũng hảnh Việt công bán, tình nghen không lấy đi tìm,
bà tả mi một đam hành hành công chăm hai bí tư,
có quan kính giúp đều chào công an thiết sản thái hoa,
xa lệnh giữ người trong trường hợp khẩn cấp,
đuổi hộ Việt anh, si ngâm hành hành hành công chăm lịch bột,
chú tài sản giữa tình,
khiển giữa đàn, về hành vi cải phá kế ấy tiền của hành hành trên,
tuu dữ một chức xe mái và một số đồ bật,
tại lựa khá bíng quan, tại các quan đều chào,
hộ Việt anh khá nhận xa đam mi cư bà,
không có tiền tư sai ninh đã từ kệ hành vi cải phá kế ấy tiền để chục tiền,
hình không ăn thiết sản thái hoa đã kết tục đều chào để xưa lý theo quy định của pháp lần.